Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we're going to talk about a procedural
algorithm. But first of all, what does procedural
mean? Procedural graphics is an exciting subfield
of computer graphics where instead of storing
a lot of stuff, information is generated on
the fly. For instance, in photorealistic rendering,
we're trying to simulate how digital objects
would look like in real life. We usually seek
to involve some scratches on our digital models,
and perhaps add some pieces of bump or dirt
on the surface of the model. To obtain this,
we can just ask the computer to not only generate
them on the fly, but we can also edit them
as we desire. We can also generate cloudy
skies and many other things where only some
statistical properties have to be satisfied,
like how many clouds we wish to see and how
puffy they should be, which would otherwise
be too laborious to draw by hand. We are scholars
after all, we don't have time for that.
There are also computer games where the levels
we can play through are not predetermined,
but also generated on the fly according to
some given logical constraints. This can mean
that a labyrinth should be solvable, or the
level shouldn't contain too many enemies that
would be impossible to defeat. The main selling
point is that such a computer game has potentially
an infinite amount of levels.
In this paper, a technique is proposed to
automatically generate procedural yarn geometry.
A yarn is a piece of thread from which we
can sew garments. The authors extensively
studied parameters in physical pieces of yarns
such as twisting and hairyness and tried to
match them with a procedural technique.
So, for instance, if in a sudden trepidation
we wish to obtain a realistic looking piece
of cotton, rayon or silk in our light simulation
programs, we can easily get a unique sample
of a chosen material, which will be very close
to the real deal in terms of these intuitive
parameters like hairyness. And we can not
only get as long or as many of these as we
desire, but can also edit them according to
our artistic vision.
The solutions are validated against photographs
and even CT scans. I always emphasize that
I really like these papers where the solutions
have some connection to real world around
us. This one is super fun indeed!
The paper is a majestic combination of beautifully
written mathematics and amazing looking results.
Make sure to have a look!
And you know, we always hear these news where
other YouTubers have problems with what is
going on in their comments section. Well,
not here with our Fellow Scholars. Have a
look at the comments section of our previous
episode. Just absolutely beautiful. I don't
even know what to say, it feels like a secret
hideout of respectful and scholarly conversations.
It's really amazing that we are building a
community of Fellow Scholars, humble people
who wish nothing else than to learn more.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!